students
your weapon will definitely
[Music]
the ram Dow
the ram Dow is a sacrificial sword that
descends from the weapons of India's
legendary rajput Warriors its broad
heavy blade flares to an ax-like
projection which is ideally suited to
the ritual beheading of large animals
such as Buffalo and goats
these sacrifices were made to the Hindu
goddess of death Kali whose symbolic eye
is often etched on the flared end of the
blade so she can watch over the ceremony
the eye of Kali can be seen on the ram
Dow wielded by a Zod the comic series
berserk
good luck blade Smiths we'll see you in
four days
[Music]
my name is Josh navarrete I was born in
Mexico and we came to the United States
when I was a kid
this is going to be a huge challenge
there's going to be tears sweat and
probably blood but I want to go so far
we got the basic profile done
everything ready for quenching
hopefully it worked yeah
I've never done finial
this was definitely very challenging I
went with a diamond looking piece but no
matter how beautiful the blade is if you
miss one of the parameters
you're out of the competition
my name is Ben Spangler when I was 15 I
was hanging out at my parents farm and I
found a bucket of blacksmithing tools I
figured let's give it a shot and I liked
it so much I kept doing it ever since so
what I'm going to try and do first is
throwing out the tank I'm going to do a
through Tang oh here it goes
boom
boom this is my homemade belt grinder
and this is how I have to start this
thing
[Music]
I'm just getting to work on the finial
after some light sanding it's going to
be done so I'm ready to go cut something
that's Sharp bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test Ram Dow Ram carcass
foreign
first you ready for this
well let's kill it again
[Music]
all right Josh let's talk about your RAM
down here the blade you have here is
sharp for every pass it makes it cuts
deeply but I also love what you have
here in sense of balance that even
though it's a chopper the recovery is
just comfortable enough to where you can
cut all the way through it feels good in
the hand it's got a great balance and
most importantly it will kill
that's awesome thank you all right Ben
it's your turn you ready for this I'm
excited let's do it
something's off about this design
[Music]
it's part of the Prime and it's part of
the designs I don't know what's going on
Ben your blade doesn't have a finial
ball it's one of the defining
characteristics of the ram Dow it was
also one of the parameters and the
judges feel that your blade cannot be
tested evenly and fairly with Josh's
please leave the forge
Josh congratulations you're the forest
and fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars come on forward and Shake our
hands bro
I cannot believe this is happening
I think what I'm gonna do with ten
thousand dollars is gonna go to open the
shop where I'm gonna be providing
workshops or at-risk youth
the Hattori Hanzo a thousand layer
katana
whoa born in 16th century Japan hatori
Hanzo also known as double Hanzo was
perhaps the most legendary Samurai to
ever live almost 400 years later in the
2003 Tarantino cult classic Kill Bill
atori Hanzo is reimagined as the modern
day bladesmith who creates a katana so
fine it would cut God
in reality the katana is the Majestic
symbol of the ancient warrior Samurai
featuring a simple but elegant
single-edged blade designed for precise
cuts and lightning fast thrusts the
dazzling Damascus layering produces not
only a beautiful piece of Steel but an
incredibly sharp and deadly Cutting Edge
good luck blade Smiths we'll see you in
five days
let's do this man all right
my name is Mike divert I am a journeyman
bladesmith and I'm an elementary school
teacher I teach Spanish and reading
there's a lot of love I pour into it but
that two months in the summertime
bladesmithing is a really good therapy
I am truly blessed to have a press and a
power hammer by hand this is very
difficult
the blade has a slight warp in it but
it's something that can be ground out so
I'm really happy right now I have my
blades ready now I just need to start
making all the handle parts
this handle has to be tight the sword is
going to be beat up
so now it's going to be wrapped in
stingray skin and Ito cord
I'm pretty happy with it
my name is Tristan Nguyen I'm 19. on a
typical day in Tristan land I work in a
pizza shop and I'm studying to be a chef
kind of pull my inspiration from
everything around me if I see something
in a video game that I really like I'll
try to make it in real life I'm going to
start by working on my 1000 layer
Damascus if I had power tools I feel
like I could have pumped this out a lot
faster and it's taking forever in order
to get the weight that I need to be able
to get the sword to length I Forge
welded mild steel to the back and the
sides of it I think it'll make the blade
stronger
I'm doing the heat treat on my Katana
with charcoal and I'm pretty nervous
this is the make or break moment if
anything goes wrong I won't be able to
finish this piece
straight whoa
my biggest deviation from the tradition
is I'm using shoelaces for my wrap it
just feels the nicest that their
shoelaces
yeah Everything feels really together
let's go hit things
[Music]
first duty is to kill to find out what
kind of leaf of damage your weapon will
do I will take your Katana and deliver
killing blows on this ballistics dummy
all right Mike New York first are you
ready yes sir let's do this
to it
[Music]
yes
Mike your Edge is razor sharp but more
importantly there's bone on your Edge
but your Edge didn't roll did not ship
and your blade stayed true
overall sir your blade
will kill thank you
Justin are you ready yes sir let's do
this
[Music]
right Trisha the balance of your blade
is very good it's light it's fast it's
easily maneuverable
but when steel meets the skull there
were some problems
your blade because serious Bend
also on the edge right here you took
some chipping
but overall looking at the dummy
I think your weapon will definitely kill
thank you
gentlemen
second duty of a Hanzo Katana is that it
is to be sharp it is said that the Hanzo
Katana is as sharp as a thousand razor
blades
now sharp blade should cut cleanly
through the tummy mats a dull blade will
crush Bend or get hung up
a doll blade is not a Hanzo Katana Mike
you're up first you ready for this yes
I'm ready
oh
your blade sir is sharp it cut cleanly
to the thickest of our tatami mats but
on the backhand slice it did not cut
completely though overall sir your sword
will cut it
thank you Tristan your turn you ready
ready as I'll ever be sir
[Music]
well Tristan your Edge is sharp you've
been cut through the tummy mats my
concern is the strength of your blade
it picked up another band now you have
two bends on your blade especially right
here close to the guard
Tristan this Hollywood competition has
been exciting and dramatic you've been
at the epicenter of all of that drama
nobody is questioning the strength of
your character however the strength of
your blade is such that we can no longer
continue to test it
for that reason I have to ask you to
please leave a forge
you were an Unstoppable force in this
competition and your hatari Hanzo
thousand-layer Katana is absolutely
deadly earning you the title of forged
and fire champion and a check for 10
grand good job brother I am forged and
fire champion and it feels awesome
[Music]
Blackbeard's Infamous Cutlass
among the most notorious pirates of the
18th century Blackbeard terrorized
Caribbean and Atlantic Merchant shipping
with his trademark Cutlass in hand it's
short but thick curved blade featured a
razor sharp edge that was ideal for
hacking and slashing during Close
Quarters combat while seizing small
vessels in his legendary battle with
Captain Robert Maynard in 1718
Blackbeard's Cutlass broke Maynard's
sword in half with a single blow
today Blackbeard's menacing presence and
expert swordmanship can still be seen in
the video game Assassin's Creed 4 Black
Flag
good luck we'll see you in five days
foreign
's an escape to where I can feel
accomplished in something that I've done
I like my knives like I like my eyebrow
thicken in one piece I'm going to make
sure the handles aren't too big but
they're not too small because there will
be multiple operators
it's a lot of Steel to be putting on a
handle
yeah I want to do a robust Edge on it I
want to keep it thick so it doesn't get
broke up so easily
[Music]
Blackbeard's Cutlass
heavy
ish
my name is Jason Crum at night I'm a
bladesmith but during the day I host a
morning radio show when I meet people
they go hey talk in your radio voice and
this is it this is me but they want me
to say something like hey hey guys and
gals kids welcome to the show I have no
press no power hammers uh my power
hammer is look at that huh that this is
the problem you get an arm like that and
one like that the plan is to take it one
piece at a time and Forge it as if I was
forging a jigsaw puzzle even though it's
gonna be cheesy and campy I'm making the
clamshell guard look like clam shells
putting the jigsaw puzzle of my handle
together went really well they put a
little skull face on the back there I'm
going to leave the edge geometry just a
little beefier just so it can stand up
to some of the brutal chopping that it's
probably gonna see he stoled me pirate
booty and now you're paying the price
[Music]
it will kill
bladesmiths to test The lethality of
your Cutlass I'm going to inflict lethal
wounds on these ballistic dummies
Jason you're up first you ready I sure
hope so Doug let's do this
[Music]
all right Jason you got a very big
handle here but at least it's got the
swells it's got an indexing to where I
hold on to it I can tell where the edge
is the weight that you have in this
weapon is so light and sense that I can
wield it even around here you've got the
clavicle into the ribs all the way
through the lungs and definitely it will
kill
all I ever wanted to hear made my day
Seth you're up next you ready get some
[Applause]
[Music]
all right Seth your sword is forward
heavy without a balance coming back I
don't know the short is going to hurt
more the dummies are mine but your
weapon sir will kill thank you
thank you
assess the strength and durability of
your swords I'll be chopping through
these bones and then attacking that Peg
Leg now remember this test is not about
what your blades do to these targets
it's about what these targets can do to
your blades
testing your up are you ready nope
foreign
[Music]
is really nice which is surprising
because you've made a two-handed Cutlass
your blade held up very well except for
the one little chip and it's not even
chip to roll
so it didn't blow out it's a good job
thank you Dave all right Seth are you
ready yes sir
all right Seth
first up
this thing's a beast it is probably a
pound heavier than your competitor's
sword
your blade I mean I can run my finger to
inhale down this I can see a couple of
glinting spots but it really didn't take
any damage
[Music]
all right blade Smiths let's find out if
there's any Edge left this is the Rope
Cut and pirate sail slash to test the
edge of your Cutlass I will cut this
rope which will raise the sail and then
I will slash the sail
this is all about what your sword will
do to the sailing rope
chasing up first ready yes sir
[Music]
alrighty Jason your Edge cut through the
Rope easily and cuts with every part
that the edge met on this pirate sale
overall sir your sword will come
awesome Seth how you feeling
good let's go let's do this
[Music]
all right Seth what are the chances you
find a very dull spot on the first cut
on the Rope
the second cut he had found another spot
that was sharp but on the sail working a
heavy sword like this affects my cuts
Jason Seth the judges have tested your
weapons and they've made a final
decision our new forged and fire
Champion is
Jason
congratulations you're the new Fortune
fire champion
Seth unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut please surrender your blade
[Music]
congratulations you are our new Forge
and fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a bundle of bullion
that's worth 10 grand how you feeling
right now
come on that's incredible Fortune fire
champion
the Celtic anthropomorphic sword
the Celtic anthropomorphic sword is an
Iron Age weapon that's both elegant and
lethal but boasts distinctive Health
displaying anthropomorphic meaning
human-like features often cast from
bronze fearsome killer that assorts
strong double-edged point can be used as
a deadly Thruster as well as Swift
slasher capable of quick attacks in
close quarters combat the classic of
Iron Age Celtic Weaponry the sword
battles on in popular culture including
the 2011 historical drama the eagle
good luck bladesmiths we'll see you in
five days good luck
my name's Bill benkey I'm from Kingsley
Michigan I'm 71 years old I've been
forging for about 40 years now
I've watched the show quite a bit and I
thought I could do that so this is my
test
time will tell
the first thing I got to do today is get
my steel cut for the Damascus I want to
try for a high layer count something
that makes the steel look shimmery in
the light that's a big building
I need to get the gaskets done the only
thing I can think of is making like a
cookie pattern
it's like this
I put an African Blackwood handle onto
it so I hope it kind of matches the
darkness that's in the Damascus I know
it'll cut I've had two Band-Aids to
prove it right here
my name is Chuck Fowler I'm from
interlocking Florida I'm
47 or 48 years old I can't remember I
grew up in a blade smithing shop my
father's been a blade Smith since I was
a kid I really want to do this
competition and see if I can actually
compete and my wife and kids wanted me
to do it
I'm gonna have to get each Billet welded
up and then incorporate both those
bullets together in order to get enough
length and width to make the sword I
grabbed a big chunk of 40 41 got the
blade completely forged I've decided to
cast directly onto my tank I capture the
details in the handle that I want to
capture it should look pretty cool
yep some of the casting was lost I don't
know what happened I've got to cast this
bronze handle one more time I am going
to try it vertical this time I'm gonna
finish filling this up Tamp it down if
it don't work this time that's it in
theory I could actually bury the handle
deep enough
to where the molten bronze would go down
and have nowhere to escape and go around
the tank
I just don't have enough time to cast
another bronze handle
what enough
I'm over it all this work for nothing my
second attempt at casting is the bust
I am done no more where I'm ready to
just quit I'm not going to complete the
sword at all
but then I gotta think about Bill it
wouldn't be fair to him so I continue on
I want to get a completed sword up there
so I'm just going to do it my way make
it look as good as I can
I had a lot of issues these past five
days uh pushed through and I'm glad I
got it done
this is the kill test to see what kind
of lethal damage your sword will do I
will take your weapon and deliver
killing blows on this Ram carcass Bill
ready for the kill
yes I am
[Music]
that's one sharp or something right Bill
let's talk about your blade right here
first up your handle feels good it's got
a nice shape to it that just fits nicely
I like the guard I like the bronze that
you have right there I can immediately
tell where the edge is this is what I
don't like about your blade
it doesn't allow me to have fun two hits
it's done this is really light fast and
sharp bill
it will kill thank you
all right Chuck it's your turn you ready
yes sir let's do this I'm feeling a
little anxious
oh wait a minute
Chuck
Doug's taking a look at your sword it's
just too heavy to wield safely the
parameters specifically called for a
sword that was light enough to wield
one-handed because your blade failed to
meet the parameters I have to ask you to
please leave the forge
well Bill you are now our new Forge of
fire Champion it's a title that comes
with a check for ten thousand dollars
thanks thanks very much I'm the forge
and fire champion
the Glade geezong
what oh
commonly seen on battlefields during the
Medieval Era the glaive geeseam was one
of the principal weapons for European
foot soldiers in combat this fearsome
pole arm evolved from the Celtic and
German custom of attaching swords or
edged weapons to the end of long wooden
poles the combination of the long convex
blade mounted to a wooden shaft was
ideal for combating enemies on Horseback
due to its reach and versatility the
glaive geesom had a signature hook or
Spike on the opposite side of Blade to
catch Riders and move enemy Pikes cheap
to produce and deadly against Cavalry
the Glade Geeson was essential on the
battlefield for hundreds of years until
it was phased out in the 18th century
good luck blade Smiths you're gonna need
it we'll see you in five days
my name is Alex Eisenberg I'm 29 years
old I own a tattoo shop and am a
full-time tattoo artist as well as Blake
Smith most of my tattoos are a
representation of something that's
happened to me and the rest of them are
just stuff that I thought was cool and I
liked and I said I want that one the
steel I've chosen to make the socket out
of is this a regular mild steel pipe my
weapon is too long for either oven and I
want to make sure I get a good heat
treat so we are running dueling others
there we go
all right good preparing the wood to be
inserted into the socket I've left it
pretty snug so it's going to be a hammer
fit a completed my weapon and I feel
great about it I put my best forward and
I left it all out there I'm excited to
see what it does and I think it'll do
well
[Music]
my name is Nick Santella I am 39 years
old and I am a geologist I would say
that being a geologist I do have a
little extra Insight in the materials
not that I have a very technical
approach to blacksmithing I'm more a
pound away see what happens
my shop is a pretty traditional setup
oh I'm still not quite getting the kind
of heat I'd like I need a bigger blower
and the biggest blower that I've got is
a shock vacuum well this is exactly what
they always tell you not to do so
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about but it's
not taking a whole lot of time for me to
wear out
it'd be easier with a big Burling man to
strike for me
good
I know it's a critical parameter to make
sure that the head doesn't come loose
but I'm getting pretty impatient I think
that's good enough
I would definitely do it different and
better if I were to do it again but you
know for here and now I'm pretty happy
with it
well it prunes
see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do I'll take your Glade
gazam deliver thrust and slashes on this
deer carcass Nick here first you ready
guess so let's do this
foreign
first up right here on your Edge it
picked up a chip
on another side of this you can feel
where the edge also rolled but this
weapon is sharp on the initial thrust
it's got a geometry right there to
penetrate it deep into the carcass your
Edge right here on slashing it lacerated
easily on the side of this deer carcass
on the third cut the weight of this
weapon is so balanced it's easy to
lacerate all the way through your weapon
will kill
all right Alex your turn
all right Alex your tip is sharp enough
to lacerate all the way through on the
slash of this Edge it's lacerated easily
on the side rib of this particular
carcass on the wide swing it did break
half of the spine off it is as you can
see a little bit on the wider side and
the heavy weapon like this a wide handle
can make it hard to control but the most
important thing
it will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the pike chop
that was intense I wasn't ready for that
often in Pike Warfare the glaves or
weapons like them are used as a
secondary line of defense to push the
pike up out of the way and or to chop at
the Pike shaft so to test the strength
and durability of your weapons including
the hook on the back I'll be pushing
these pipes up into position then
chopping at them with the blades all
right Nick you're up first you ready yes
sir
thank you
[Music]
all right so Nick it doesn't look like
your weapon took any more damage to the
edge the weight of your blade is very
nicely balanced the good design
definitely a strong blade nicely done
thank you Alex you ready yes sir
don't break it be nice
that was brutal dude
first off your blade did take some
damage here they're very small chips and
rolls
your flanges here are just wide enough
though when I pushed forward I managed
to grab two rows of Pikes and push them
back at the same time balance is nice on
it the shaft is pretty wide it's not too
big but it's right on the outside edge
of what's comfortable for my hand but
everything held up everything's solid
thank you all right gentlemen now it's
time for the sharpness test to test the
sharpness of your blade I'll be cutting
these ropes now that releases the bag
and I'll be cutting the bag now unlike
the strength test this is all about what
your weapons do to these targets Nick
you're up first you ready
pretty cool yeah well Nick cut through
the bags really cleanly and what I
really like is the balance of this
weapon it's very easy to maneuver it
didn't have to fight the weapon nicely
done thank you all right Alex are you up
you ready yes sir
thank you
[Music]
all right your blade is wicked sharp
this passed right through the rope with
very little resistance at all and it cut
the bags beautifully the balance of your
blade is a little bit more to the tip
so the one thing about this blade when I
cut with it is slowing it down after the
cut but it's a beautiful cutter did a
great job thank you
Nick Alex you both done an incredible
amount of work on your finale weapons
however there can only be one forged and
fire champion and that champion is
Nick
congratulations you are our next Fortune
fire champion
Alex please surrender your blade
Nick congratulations you are a new
forged fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for 10 grand
good job
I got to make some really cool stuff
meet some really cool people and be in
Champion that's just a really cool bonus
foreign